so I heard when I was doing the I was
reading the pre-interview this I had no
idea that y'all overtook me in 2005 well
we didn't I feel like I just got really
cool no no one cared about us since 2005
we were just coming up and basically to
get other gigs we listed the other acts
that we'd opened up for but that really
just meant that we were on like the
outside stage in the parking lot while
you were playing for 40-thousand hope
just get a lot of gigs after thank you
we are you 20% now your real happiness
begins uh yeah so this has been you know
quite the crazy year for the family you
know just a year ago right now we had
just started recording music to get
together again and you know looking a
year later we're finishing up the first
leg of a crazy tour and and also the
album you know happiness begins but it
all started with a documentary which we
called chasing happiness which was kind
of just to tell our story of her
childhood you know her father was a
pastor and we had a pretty crazy journey
in the church and then into our music
career together and we had really no
intention of getting the band back
together
but after filming for a little while and
kind of healing some of those family
wounds that were there from our years of
working together in the past we were
able to look at this with a fresh view
and and really kind of all in different
ways find our happiness and so we we
went for it and it's been an
unforgettable year it's been really
amazing that's really cool like not only
I mean I get like the fans are excited
about it but it's way more cool for you
and your family like that's a hard thing
to like I mean that's my road family
over there and it's it's hard to all be
together all the time especially when
you're elated I can't even imagine that
so that's really cool but this is really
special to share that with documentary
would you released it if y'all wouldn't
have gotten together I think so yeah I
think you know we had spent money making
it so we probably yeah and I think it
was an important story to tell you know
and that was kind of I think the thing
that was to us so special about it is
that there was no intention to come back
and do this again at the beginning but
when we actually just sat down to the
hard work that uh you know most families
have to do we all go through things the
people we love and whether it's the
family you choose yeah you got to go
through it
and and we did and we look at the other
side and we're all kind of in the best
place in our lives
I know you're all married now yeah
Robyn's got two kids and it's a
beautiful time and to have been able to
go through that with your families is I
think we're all really grateful and
aware of how unique it is and so this
has just been so cool I will say you
have like um the most famous family ever
it's like looking at everyone lives it
in your family tree I'm like okay well
it's that those kids are gonna be like
they're not gonna know what normal is
we're like have some cool aunts it's
amazing y'all should have written that
you shouldn't but you should have a
reality show I just want to see it I
want to watch the dynamic of all those
famous people in one family that's I
think man might break up again if we I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this